Усім привіт!
Я Олена Оперчук.
Запрошую вас, шановні десятикласники,
на урок української літератури.
На попередніх уроках зі своїми
вчителями ви говорили про те,
що починаючи з кінця ХІХ
століття і до кінця ХХ століття
в літературі, власне – в мистецтві
переважає стильова течія,
яка називається модернізм.
Тож пригадаємо.
Модернізм, в перекладі з
французької, означає сучасний.
Це комплекс
літературно-мистецьких напрямків,
який виник наприкінці
ХІХ, на початку ХХ століття.
Крім того, хочу вам нагадати,
що модернізм – це загальна назва,
але у ньому є ще й напрями,
з деякими ви знайомилися на уроках
української літератури в тому числі.
Тож розпочинаємо.
Отже, імпресіонізм.
Пригадайте, будь ласка,
хто у нас є найяскравішим
представником імпресіонізму
в українській літературі?
Звісно, Михайло Коцюбинський.
Експресіонізм.
З цією стильовою течією ви
познайомилися не так давно.
Адже найяскравішим представником в
українській літературі є Василь Стефаник.
Також модернізм – це неоромантизм,
неореалізм, неокласицизм,
футуризм і символізм.
З кожним із цих напрямків
ми будемо з вами знайомитись
на уроках української літератури
далі і говоритимемо про найяскравіших
представників саме в
нашій українській літературі.
Варто також зазначити, що соціальні,
економічні, суспільні чинники – це
все не могло пройти повз мистецтво.
Воно, звісно що, зумовило
розвиток модернізму, як такого.
Модернізм присутній в
будь-якій галузі мистецтва:
і в образотворчому,
і в музичному, і в літературі.
Тож пропоную вам
зануритися трішечки глибше.
А що ж відбувалось не тільки в державі
наприкінці ХІХ, початку ХХ
століття, а і в літературі в тому числі?
Варто зазначити, що
на початку ХХ століття
діяли як представники
старої школи романтизму:
це і Яків Щоголів, і Пантелеймон Куліш,
а також і більш старші письменники:
це і Іван Франко, і Михайло Старицький,
і Олена Бджілка, і Борис Грінченко.
Крім того, з’являється нове покоління.
Власне, ось це нове покоління, воно і дало
розвиток модернізму
в українській літературі.
Це і Леся Українка, і Олександр Олесь, і
Богдан Лепкий, і багато-багато інших імен.
З творчістю письменників
ви будете знайомитись далі.
Якщо говорити про поезію, то
вона твориться різними мовами.
Це і російська, і українська, і
польська, і італійська, і чеська,
і багато-багато інших мов.
Власне, найбільше розвиваються
такі жанри як філософська лірика,
громадянська лірика,
пейзажна лірика, інтимна лірики.
І зовсім іншим постає ліричний герой.
Тому що раніше він був такий
меланхолійний, мрійливий,
взагалі відірваний від реального життя, то
в роки становлення модернізму в літературі,
ліричний герой – він уже
вольова особистість, яка мріє.
І найважливіше, що ці мрії
дають йому сили для боротьби.
Поезія характеризується,
перш за все, – заглибленням
заглибленням в себе,
в глибини людського я.
Перейдімо до наступного пункту.
Найяскравішим представником
модернізму в українській літературі
наприкінці ХІХ-початку ХХ століття
є угруповання «Молода муза»,
яке виникло на Галичині.
До даного літературного
угрупування входили:
Петро Карманський, Богдан Лепкий,
Василь Пачовський, Михайло Яцків,
Сидір Твердохліб, Остап Луцький.
Всіх їх об’єднало навколо себе,
по-перше, мета, про
що я скажу дещо пізніше,
і, по-друге, журнал «Світ»,
про що також згадаю.
Тож всі письменники, які
входили до «Молодої музи»,
будемо їх називати «молодомузівці»,
вони для себе поставили певну мету,
яка полягала в тому,
що варто служити красі
і не обмежувати авторів щодо
літературних течій, і не тільки модерних.
Переважна більшість поетів, які входили
до «Молодої музи», були символістами.
Свою творчість вони творили за аналогією
з угрупованнями: «Молода Бельгія»,
«Молода Німеччина», «Молода
Австрія», «Молода Польща».
Тому зразки західної
літератури були присутні,
але у нас в Україні це
все набувало своїх рис.
Власне, «Молода муза»
з’явилась не просто так,
тому що на початку
вона мала свого мецената,
і це був священик Михайло Світенький.
Саме цей священик
фінансував видання книг,
а також газету
«Будучність» і журнал «Світ».
Коли ж Остап Луцький в газеті «Діло»
опублікував такий своєрідний маніфест,
в якому висловив думку про те,
що «молодомузівці» – це угруповання,
яке має виступати поза інтересами релігії,
в тому числі не має наслідувати
народницьких, просвітницьких нюансів,
то це різко засудив Іван Франко.
Як ви пам’ятаєте, він був ще й одним
із найвідоміших літературних критиків.
Але, якби там не було, Іван Франко не
вважав модернізм ворожим нашій літературі.
Іван Франко усвідомлює, що ось
так поступово модернізм український
абсолютно спокійно виходить в одне
русло з модернізмом європейським.
Зупинимося на тому, а який ліричний
герой у представників «Молодої Музи»?
Перш за все – це людина, яка
заблукала в цьому трагічному світі.
Вона десь втікає у вимріяні далі.
Але ліричний герой –
вільний у своєму виборі,
своєму самовираженні, своєму світобаченні.
Власне, ми з вами бачимо і
спостерігаємо таку тенденцію,
що «молодомузівці» – вони намагалися
інтегрувати в українську літературу
нові теми, а саме це: світова скорбота,
самогубство, заглиблення в суть явищ,
які перебувають за межами нашого пізнання.
«Молодомузівці» були проти одноманітності.
«Молодомузівців» звинуватили у
відриві від національних традицій.
Їх звинуватили ледве не у
зраді громадських інтересів.
Хоча насправді це було абсолютно не так.
Тому що ті, хто входив до
угрупування «Молода Муза»,
всього-навсього відмовилися
зображувати побутовий етнографізм.
Вони змальовували соціальні конфлікти,
але по-новому, по-своєму,
оскільки намагалися заглибитись
у психологію самих героїв.
Наступною знаковою подією у розвитку
модернізму в українській літературі
наприкінці ХІХ-на початку ХХ століття
є вихід журналу «Українська хата».
Саме в березні 1909 року
в Києві він і почав виходити.
Це був перший друкований
орган українського модернізму.
Навколо цього видання зібралася
група талановитих митців-новаторів.
Митці вважали, що необхідно
відходити від примітивізму
і треба вливати щось нове.
Власне, в основі творчості всіх тих,
хто друкувався в «Українській хаті»,
була людина. Не просто
людина, а людина-індивід
і щось на зразок – надлюдина.
Таке собі своєрідне наслідування Ніцше.
І ця людина – вона єдина та
неповторна, зі своїм світом.
Свого часу в «Українській
хаті» друкувалися такі митці,
як Олександр Олесь, Микола Вороний,
Ольга Кобилянська, Володимир Винниченко.
Також уже в ті часи пробу пера зробили
потім відомі нам Максим
Рильський, Павло Тичина.
В цьому виданні з’являються також
переклади інших авторів, західних.
Ідеться про Шарля Бодлера, Кнута
Гамсуна та багато-багато інших.
Переважна більшість авторів, які
друкувалися в «Українській хаті»,
представляли своєю творчістю таки стильові
течії як неоромантизм та імпресіонізм.
І один із найвідоміших літературних
критиків того часу Сергій Єфремов
говорив про те, що ці
автори є декадентами,
а їхні твори це – забавки
рафінованого міщанства.
Погоджуватися чи ні – думка кожного з нас.
Як ви пам’ятаєте,
Сергію Єфремову навіть Франко із
«Зів’ялим листям» не дуже подобався.
Якби там не було, але ті, хто
друкувався в «Українській хаті»,
абсолютно нічим не поступались
європейським письменникам.
І очевидно, якби не І Світова
війна, то це переросло б у щось інше.
Власне, «Українська хата»
перестала існувати у 1914 році.
Помітним явищем в українській літературі
став вихід альманаху
«З-над хмар і з долин»,
який упорядкував і видав у
1903 році в Одесі Микола Вороний.
Варто зазначити, що це теж – помітне
явище в розвитку українського модернізму.
Оскільки запрошуючи до
роботи того чи іншого автора,
Микола Вороний, як і всі ті,
хто друкувався в альманасі –
вони мали дотримуватися своєрідного
гасла. А саме, що письменство –
воно має бути вільним, національним,
стояти на засадах естетизму і досконалості.
Видання було особливе,
тому що розпочато його було
віршем Івана Франка «Миколі Вороному».
За ним слідувала відповідь Миколи
Вороного – поезія «Іванові Франкові».
Власне, в даному
альманасі друкувалися твори
і поетичні, і прозові, письменники з
Галичини, Буковини, Наддніпрянщини,
які на межі ХІХ і ХХ століття
вийшли на широкий загал.
Микола Вороний користувався
одним і найважливішим правилом –
треба об’єднати під однією
обкладинкою тих письменників,
які зорієнтовані на пошуки – пошуки
філософські, пошуки естетичні.
І тому Микола Вороний
проголосив такі слова:
«Грубого реалізму я не визнаю».
Звертаю вашу увагу на те, що модернізм
позначився не лише в прозі і поезії,
а також і на драматичних творах.
Власне, драматургія останніх десятиліть
ХІХ і початку ХХ століття – це щось нове.
Це нові форми, це нові сценічні жанри.
Відповідно, це все отримало
назву «Нова українська драма».
Саме в цей час з’являються
письменники драматурги -
Леся Українка, Олександр Олесь,
Володимир Винниченко та інші.
Найхарактернішими рисами
української драми у нас є перш за все те,
що необхідно доволі точно відображати
середовище, в якому відбуваються події.
Плюс до всього – необхідно
докласти максимум зусиль,
аби розкрити внутрішній конфлікт героя.
Плюс дуже часто
використовується підтекст, дискусії.
І, як результат, у нас
з’являються нові жанри драми.
Це – соціальна драма, психологічна
драма і інтелектуальна драма.
Трішечки зупинімося на драматургах
кінця ХІХ-початку ХХ століття.
Перш за все - новим ім’ям в драматургії,
новою формою стала Леся Українка,
оскільки саме в цьому жанрі
автор по-своєму, по-новому дивиться
на страждання, боротьбу,
жертовність особистості.
Оскільки її Мавка з «Лісової
пісні», Міріам із «Одержимої»,
Долорес із «Камінного господаря» – всі
ці героїні, вони борються за свою свободу,
за свою внутрішню свободу,
за своє духовне визволення
і шукають своє місце на цій землі.
Не можна не згадати і Олександра Олеся,
тому що до нової драми він
також має неабиякий дотик,
оскільки його драматичний
етюд «По дорозі в казку» –
теж щось нове, щось незвичне.
Події, зображенні в цьому творі,
відбуваються в невідомому часі,
в невідомому місці, але головний герой –
він веде народ в нову країну і
зневірившись, гине
за мить до цього щастя.
Саме тому дехто говорить про те, що
драматичний етюд «По дорозі в казку»
можна поставити на один
щабель із «Мойсеєм» Івана Франка.
Детальніше із драмою-феєрією
«Лісова пісня»,
з драматичним етюдом «По дорозі в казку»
ви познайомитеся на уроках
літератури навіть цього року.
Тож підсумуємо все те,
про що я вам розповідала.
Перше і найважливіше те, що літературний
процес з кінця ХІХ-початку ХХ століття –
він нагадує нам такий різнобарвний
килим, зітканий з абсолютно різних
і цікавих ниток та
стильових течій модернізму.
Шукання митців цього
часу ще раз доводять,
що література не може жити,
працювати, існувати ізольовано.
Вона, ось ця література,
покликана зберігати
національну ідентичність, але не зупинятися
на старому, а постійно оновлюватись.
Тож поки що все, але без домашнього
завдання ми сьогодні не підемо.
Тож запишіть, будь
ласка, домашнє завдання.
До нових зустрічей! До побачення!